Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 33rd episode!
3-3.
It feels like it was just the other day that was a 2-2.
Moco-chan!
Aren't you a bit energetic?
Yeah.
I saw some first-time Ruffians joining us for FUWAMOCO Morning today.
So just so you know, don't get confused.
No confusion.
No misunderstanding.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
No Thursdays.
Why is that, Moco-chan?
Because it's not FUWAMOCO.
Yeah!
And the show is hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
This is an interesting discovery.
A bit yappy today, huh?
A little bit yappy today.
Ruffians, have you seen Pero around recently?
I think they have.
Because we have another Pero Sighting!
Where is he this time?
It looks like maybe this Ruffian was a bit rudely disturbed when they were trying to clean up all the leaves.
Was the Ruffian disturbed or was Pero disturbed?
Good question.
Well, you know, Ruffians, we talked about this a little bit before.
Moco-chan, you like the leaves, right?
Pero, Pero enjoys a good pile of all leaves too.
He doesn't have to worry about bugs or dirt as much, though.
Yeah, he's lucky.
Yeah, he's round.
He's not too fluffy, not too fuzzy.
And he's pretty easy to watch, too.
Yeah, he can clean well.
Yeah.
Although, you know, Pero does have to worry about grass stains sometimes.
He does stain pretty easily, you know.
But... Yeah... Ruffians.
I'll be honest.
You know, I've always sort of thought
I wanna see a tie-dye Pero.
You know, it's sort of off-season.
But he sort of look like an easter egg, right?
It'd be fun.
I don't know if you'd like that though.
I don't care!
But anyways, you know the fall leaves are super da fun.
Right, Ruffians?
And if you look, look really closely, some of the leaves in this pile kind of look like Pero's wings too.
They're spiky and kind of like a...
Maybe not quite a pale purple, but a pretty deep purple too.
You know maybe that's what attracted him to the pile in particular to begin with.
We're glad that he disappeared before you had to use violence though.
Went once that.
You know that might not have ended up well for you.
BAU BAU!
Good job getting up there and cleaning up those leaves.
It must be cold, but you did it.
BAU BAU!
I love you.
There's some exciting news coming up!
Our senpai...
Kaela-senpai is gonna be having her 3D showcase!
Kaela-senpai's hololive ID is gonna be having her 3D showcase this Friday at 6am PT.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Any ideas, Ruffians?
Real life Minecraft!
That'd be pretty cool, too.
I was kind of thinking that could be possible, too.
I'm really curious.
You know, seeing Zetta-senpai have such an eye-opening experience, too.
We're really looking forward to seeing Kaela-senpai's showcase as well!
Just what will she have?
You know it!
Super duper curious!
Good luck, Kaela-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Make sure you watch Ruffians, okay?
You know, it's just a couple hours before FUWAMOCO Morning, so... That's pretty easy to fit in the schedule, right?
Just wake up a little bit.
A little bit early.
You know it's Kaela-senpai's special day, right?
12 hours 3D!
The happiness doesn't end!
Another senpai.
Hakui Koyori senpai!
She just had her 150th episode of Asa Koyo yesterday!
Bye-bye!
Ruffians, you've seen Asa Koyo, right?
Yeah.
We're so happy for you!
You know, we're sure it's a lot of work, but it's a show that's so well-loved by everyone.
We hope that FUWAMOCO Morning can continue for a long time, just like Asahiyo, and become just as well-loved too.
And Ruffians, it just wasn't the 115th episode, but Advent and even FUWAMOCO Morning from last Friday was featured on the episode too!
I'm the 50th.
We're really happy.
Thank you so much for your support by Holodog.
BAU BAU!
And you might have caught it the other day.
There's been some news.
While this week, Advent, we're having a special Halloween party that we're putting on.
But, not just that.
There's been...
Very special Halloween voice drama that was released!
BAU BAU!
Have you listened?
Have you?
I don't know.
There might be some Ruffians that still don't know, but this voice drama went on sale and it's called The Manor.
It's very different from the usual voice parts because this time we became different roles and acted out a spooky mystery.
It was a really fun experience, building on characters.
I'm Maria.
I'm Moco-chan.
I'm Aria.
I'm acting out the story and everything, too!
It was good!
You liked it?
There's both a Japanese script and an English script so you can check them both out But the audio is only in English It's only English But we hope that you'll check it out on the whole store and support us
You
And Advent too!
You know we did our best!
It was really fun, so we hope that we can do more stuff like that in the future.
It would be nice to be able to get more opportunities like this to grow ourselves and try new things.
And Ruffians, if you check it out, then that means you'll be able to hear FUWAMOCO's first attempt.
Why are you laughing?
First attempt!
It was our first attempt.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Look, Biboo's crying!
You wanna hear why Biboo's crying?
Why?
You have to check it out!
There's definitely a lot of different emotions, so... BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
End of the happy news for today.
I don't know.
This is a bit of a complicated feeling.
Is it complicated?
Yeah.
Ruffians, we have an apology to make.
But it's not to you.
It's not to you.
Why would we apologize?
Did you see our Twitter this morning, Ruffians?
Did you?
Well, our neighbors
My poor, poor neighbors.
Actually, we might have been a little bit loud last night, but it wasn't our fault!
You know, actually, we were up all night recording a song.
Even though we're supposed to be quiet at night time so that everyone can sleep.
Just this once we needed to do this.
Just this once, okay?
Just this once.
We're very quiet almost all of the time otherwise.
No BAU BAUing either.
No.
You know we have a strict rule of no streaming horror games during night because of this.
Yeah.
Because you know, we just can't control ourselves.
Yeah, but we thought that maybe just this once would be okay.
But, you know what?
Our neighbors though, they're really really noisy most of the time.
Even past midnight too.
Now we can hear shouting and hammering and chopping.
Even the songs that they're listening to on TV at all times of day and night.
It doesn't stop.
Once we even sung along with the lyrics of a song that they were playing.
But you know, we never ever complain.
It's okay.
You know, instead we like to think of it as like a nice sign that we're not alone.
Yeah.
Yeah, so we hope that our singing maybe didn't keep them up.
Maybe they could look at it positively.
Yeah, maybe it was like a lullaby.
Yeah, but if it wasn't, sorry neighbors.
BAU BAU.
Ruffians, would you be okay with a lullaby through your walls?
Bite them.
Early access!
I don't know if I want to bite them.
Bite them?
Why would I bite them?
It would not be that tasty.
Early access, right!
Early access!
BAU BAU!
There's a misunderstanding, Ruffians.
That we kind of need to clear up.
It's very important.
There's been a lot of misunderstandings this week, Moco-chan.
I thought we were doing better.
I thought so too.
Well... This is something we need you to understand, okay?
Because you're the one who's misunderstanding this.
Okay?
It's not our fault.
We saw that there are a number of Ruffians.
You seem to have an improper understanding of this.
Yeah.
Yeah, you seem to think that we always somehow have to mention or like include the fact that we're sweaty during every one of our streams.
It's not the case.
It's not.
Not at all!
Ruffians!
Ruffians.
What the heck?! !
What the heck?
You know it.
We don't enjoy it.
But it's hot!
It's really, really hot!
You know, especially when we're focused on gaming or playing something scary.
You know it.
Especially when we're cramped close together in a room for a really long time.
You know, the heat makes scary games even more intense for us.
We're fighting for our lives.
Okay?
It's important that we let you know, Ruffians.
We are sweating!
And that is how hard we are in that world and the reality of the game, okay?
Real gamers, you got that?
It's not that we want to, it just happens.
And so, you know, if my hand slips and then I make a mistake in the game, or if Fuwawa's hand slips and she makes a mistake in the game, it's probably just because we're sweaty.
But Ruffians, we told you before though, you know, sometimes it even gets to 32 or 33 degrees Celsius in our room.
It's hot.
It's not even summer anymore either.
It's not summer, it's just hot.
Yeah.
You know, you would be sweating too, okay?
So don't misunderstand, okay?
It's not like we want to share this info with you, okay?
Yeah, but it's just, it's important info to add to our commentary, you know?
Understood.
True gaming.
Okay, true gaming.
Okay.
Run the AC.
We can't, the Ruffians.
You'd hear it.
And it'd be like... No.
That would be bad because then you'd get confused.
Is that the AC or is that Moco-chan speaking?
You wouldn't know.
Pain!
Please don't misunderstand, okay?
It's important information.
Okay, got it.
You don't want to hear the AC, okay?
BAU BAU.
But my toes will stay warm, no matter how hot it is.
Understood.
Understandable.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Now that the Ruffians understand that, maybe we'll let them understand something extra nice.
We'll let them understand!
We will!
Ruffians.
We know you're tired.
We've been streaming a lot recently, right?
We know.
Listen to us stream.
And we play Cookies and Cream for almost 7 hours!
Right!
It's been a bit busy, huh?
So we thought, you know, we'd try to take things a bit easier this week.
But...
De-den!
No!
We decided to do a bonus stream on Thursday!
Now on Thursday at 7am PT, 14 o'clock GMT, and 11pm JST, we'll be playing holo no Suika!
A family game similar to other games you may know of.
Yeah, we've been seeing a lot of our senpai playing it, so we're curious.
Ruffians, have you seen senpai playing it yet?
Are there hololive playing it?
Yes, yes, yes!
Hopefully, you decide to check it out with us too!
You know, the fruit and... and... fruit are cute too.
But, our senpai are... are even cuter, right Ruffians?
Right?
Of course.
You know the right answer.
Of course, of course, of course.
Fruit!
Or Horoman.
Right, right, right!
It'll definitely be lots of fun for sure, okay?
Let's all do our best to get a high score!
Yeah, and it's at 7am, so it's a little bit earlier than FUWAMOCO Morning is usually, but maybe... Maybe it's sort of like a FUWAMOCO Morning on Thursday.
On Thursday.
So... Maybe I was being silly earlier, huh?
Please, we hope to see you there!
BAU BAU!
Happy!
That's all they need for the happy for today.
You don't need any other happy for today, huh?
Well, I guess the Ruffians did understand now.
They don't misunderstand anymore.
No misunderstandings anymore.
Maybe!
I'll say something.
Really?
Ruffians!
Hello!
It's me, Mococo!
And it's time!
Yeah!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And this time, you're gonna hear from me, Mococo!
Are your eyes feeling a bit sleepy?
Is your body feeling a bit slow?
Well then, I have a secret to fix it.
But, only if you promise to follow along with me, okay?
You promise?
Okay, you promise?
Okay.
First, let's stretch a bit to the left.
Okay, good.
Now, let's stretch a bit to the right!
And now, let's spin ourselves around!
Spin, spin!
Okay, and next,
Let's close our eyes really really tight.
And open!
Last step, okay.
Let's let out a hearty BAU BAU.
On the count of three.
Okay!
Three!
Two!
One!
BAU BAU!
There.
Do you feel a bit more ready to take on today?
You should!
You're doing great even if sometimes your body doesn't want to keep up with you, okay?
But make sure you do give yourself some good rest time, okay?
I believe in you and your continued hard work every day.
I know you're doing your best.
Even if sometimes no one else notices it.
What's important is that you recognize all your hard work.
Because, you know, you know yourself best of all.
You can do it!
We believe in you!
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Wow, I feel ready.
I feel ready too, Moco-chan.
Are you all good for taking today on the right paw?
I am.
Hopefully the Ruffians are too.
Now on to our Doggie of the Day!
Who's our Doggie of the Day today?
We have...
It's Steven!
Steven is the Doggie of the Day today!
Steven loves science, so you know he was checking out the solar eclipse with his Ruffian.
You know what?
When I first saw this, I was a bit shocked.
What?
I was a bit scared.
Oh no, right?
I thought he had a cleaver through his head.
You know, like a Halloween costume?
No, no.
Steven's just trying to check out the eclipse safely.
That's it!
Same!
Ruffians thought the same, right?
What?
I don't know.
Ruffians are silly, but you know what?
I saw a bunch of Ruffians go out to see the eclipse.
That's pretty cool.
That's nice.
Yeah, we hope you enjoyed it, Ruffians!
We didn't even realize it happened.
If you had told us, we could have gone and seen it too so that we could have watched it all together, but... Well... That's okay, that's okay.
It was cool?
I'm glad for you.
I'm really glad.
BAU BAU!
My god, Steven enjoyed it too!
At least Steven enjoyed it in our place.
Well, how does Steven BAU BAU?
Maybe like a raspy BAU BAU?
I think he does it with a lot of teeth, like...
I don't know.
Don't you think it's maybe loud enough to reach the moon?
Nothing stops Steven from knowledge!
Science dog.
Or also maybe hugs from his beloved Ruffian.
Science and hugs.
That's what he likes.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Next we have... Today I went on a walk!
Where did this Ruffian go today?
De-den!
Pretty!
This Ruffian...
They made a haiku when they went on a walk too.
That's nice.
A haiku about the changing seasons.
Fall.
A leaf falls.
Austere.
Trees fall.
Unnoticed.
Silent.
Breathe floats, yet falls still.
Beautiful.
It looks like it was a really peaceful walk when you went, and maybe that you were able to reflect on the changing seasons and the world around you!
So nice!
You know, and despite it maybe not being the greatest weather, you still went and you did it!
That's great!
We hope you continue to write lots of haikus too!
BAU BAU!
I like the reflection.
Right is very pretty.
Very relaxing.
Good for poetry.
Well, we also received a Question of the Day, too.
Let's see.
De-den!
Question for FUWAMOCO!
Do you two have any advice on how to make a tough decision?
There may be some Ruffians who feel like they are at a crossroads and can't decide which direction to go.
Very interesting hearing from my oshis.
BAU BAU!
It's a good question.
You know, we've had to make some very tough decisions in the past too.
And actually, one thing that has never failed us when we're really stuck and not sure what to do.
It's a bit simple, so you won't laugh, right, Ruffians?
Don't laugh, okay?
Don't laugh.
It's actually a pros and cons list!
You'd be surprised!
Don't laugh!
Don't laugh, okay?
There was actually one time where we both had to make a super important decision and we thought
It's silly how it's just something simple, right?
But you know, in the end, it was the right decision that was it.
So we don't regret it at all.
So, our advice to you Ruffians is that if you ever have to make a tough decision, get a notebook and make your pros and cons columns and then start thinking really hard.
Eventually you'll find the answer that you're searching for.
I think so.
That's our advice.
As long as you're happy with it.
It's important to think about all the things, all the situations, what you think is best for you.
We're good at thinking about lots of stuff, huh?
Sometimes maybe a bit too good, huh?
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the really good questions!
And thank you, Ruffians, for all your submissions today!
We're always looking for more Doggies of the Days.
Doggies of the Days.
See the walks you're going on.
Questions, questions, questions, questions.
And Pero Sightings too.
Please.
Please send your submissions in a foot!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a show we make together.
Yeah, but don't forget the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
BAU BAU!
For our next stream, we have... In case you didn't know, today is...
De-den!
Resident Evil Wednesday!
Yeah!
Tonight is a part of Advent Halloween Party.
We'll be playing a game that's pretty spooky.
Resident Evil 4 Remake.
But as Moco-chan, you kind of said there.
I don't know.
Do the Ruffians hear it?
But today is Wednesday!
Which means, by rule of FUWAMOCO, we have to play Resident Evil 4 because it's Resident Evil Wednesday this month!
Resident Evil Wednesday.
Moco-chan, you got it all wrong.
Can you say it properly?
Resident Evil... No!
Start again.
Resident... No!
I can hear it.
Why is it an evil Wednesday?
Yeah.
But I don't know if it's getting any easier for us because now that the zombies are infected with the weird ham virus.
I don't want to spend that much ammo on them.
Please help us, okay, Ruffians?
It's getting scarier, I think.
BAU BAU!
Well, let's take a peek at our schedule for this week!
Our schedule!
We have lots of spooky streams coming up, but we keep on mentioning it because we're really looking forward to our FUWAMOCO Valkenborn Party!
We're really excited because, you know, we're gonna be singing a few songs that we didn't think we'd be able to sing, but they're some of our favorites.
We didn't think we'd be ever able to sing them.
No.
We worked really hard so that we can sing them.
Just for you, okay?
Lots of special surprises.
But you might not be too familiar with some of the songs.
But we'd like it if you could still come and take a listen.
Or maybe you can enjoy them while munching on some spooky snacks and howling along with us too.
Does that sound good, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today for our very special FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
Well, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Johansson!
BAU BAU!
Flex!
Stick play!
BAU BAU!
I'm your tiger!
Taka!
BAU BAU!
F-turn!
Torch!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!